من تحت ركام المباني ترفع اياديهم طلبا
للنجاح الانقاذ وان ثقلت ليست وحدها
العائق امام الخروج بين الارض والسماء
عقبات اخرى تقف حائلا بينها عنصر الزمن
كلما مرت الساعات والايام تتضاءل فرص
انقاذ من هم اسفل حطام البنايات في سوريا
او في تركيا سباق مع الزمن فوفقا لدراسات
بحثيه تعد الساعات الاربع والعشرون الاولى
هي الاهم لانقاذ الضحايا وبدءا من اليوم
الخامس تتضائل فرص الانقاذ نظرا لغياب
عوامل التنفس والماء والهواء لكن
الاستثناء والامل يظلان حاضرين مثل ما حدث
في زلزالي اليابان وهايتي تسييس الازمه
التجاذبات السياسيه قد تؤثر على وصول
المساعدات الى سوريا وتقف حائلا امام فرق
الانقاذ عوائق دفعت اطراف الازمه دوليا
واماميا بالدعوه لتنحيه السياسه جانبا
يجب الحرص على ان لا تكون هناك اي عوائق
تؤخر ايصال المساعدات لانقاذ حياه الناس
في سوريا
الدعم والامداد امدادات من هنا وهناك
وتضامن دولي لكنها ليست كافيه لزياده
اعداد الناجين من تحت ركام المباني
نوعيه المساعدات والامدادات تحتاج الى
تدقيق فتظل اليات الانقاذ المتخصصه في هذا
الشان ومصادر الطاقه اللازمه لها لا غنى
عنها الطقس هطول الامطار في بعض المناطق
وتجمد الطقس في مناطق اخرى شكل خطوره على
العالقين تحت الانقاض والاسواق ان الاوضاع
الجويه السيئه عرقله وصول فرق الانقاذ
غياب التنسيق تدفق لفرق الدعم من مختلف
انحاء العالم ومساعدات تنطلق نحو سوريا
وتركيا من كل اتجاه لكن التنسيق مع جهات
الاغاثه يتطلب معلومات وحصرا لاكثر
المناطق تضررا فيما تبقى مواصله الجهد
الامل الوحيد في العثور على مزيد من
الناجين علي السمان العربيه